heads up about traffic all around unlv
over the next few days more than fifteen
hundred kids are moving into their dorms
now the newest member of the eight news
now good day team candace charles
joining us from the drop in maryland
parkway campus hey candace what's new
for rebel students this year
good morning good morning folks yes one
of the largest freshman classes in uob
history is set to join returning
students for the start of the fall
semester on monday but today you will
start to see those new faces as they
move into their new homes right here
behind me now moving will take place
throughout the next three days with each
day starting around 8 in the morning
cover 19 safety protocols such as
sanitation stations and setting aside a
portion of rooms to meet demand for
single occupancy requests remain in
place new this year furniture in the
residence halls more single rooms for
first year incoming students and a
meditation garden in addition to two
in-house counselors we'll be stationed
in the residence halls to offer mental
and physical health resources and
programming the university has
contracted out movers to help speed up
the process security will be on site and
ras intend to help with traffic
we're hoping people adhere to their
schedule so we're moving some
you know some all over the place but not
everyone at once and we'll still have
some
jumbling we'll stop some lines i think
that is just one of the things
now uw resident staff asked that the
community avoid parking around the
campus if possible that really would be
helpful throughout the next few days you
can expect traffic along tropicana
thomas and max center as well coming up
i'll tell you the advice that the staff
here has for you on welcoming those new
students now classes start next monday
august 29th for now live from the unlv
campus i'm candice charles 8 news now